et si l'Ukraine perdait la guerre contre
la Russie c'est la question longtemps
restée tabou qui commence à se poser
chez les alliés occidentaux de l'Ukraine
après 21 mois d'une guerre sanglante les
mauvaises nouvelles s'accumulent pour
Kiev depuis l'échec de sa
contreoffensive qui se heurte depuis
juin à la puissante ligne de défense
russe sans réussir à la percer d'abord
sur le terrain militaire où les forces
russes ont démontré une capacité
d'adaptation hors du commun
transformation des tactiques de guerre
usage massif des drones suicides ou
encore recours à la guerre électronique
l'arrière n'a jamais été aussi solide
plus de 385000 conscrits apâés par des
salaires élevés auraient rejoint les
rangs de l'armée russe cette année alors
que le complexe militaro industriel
tourne à plein régime sur le plan
économique le krémelin peut se targer
d'une croissance qui devrait dépasser
celle de la zone euro en 2023 malgré les
sanctions occidentales sans précédent le
temps joue contre nous prévient l'ancien
ministre des Affaires étrangère
ukrainien Pavlo klimkin et le conflit
israélo-palestinien qui a brutalement
fait disparaître la question ukrainienne
de l'actualité fait désormais craindre
le pire nous sommes engagés dans une
compétition avec Israël pour les
munitions américaines il n'est pas sûr
que les États-Unis a le budget suffisant
pour fournir assez de munitions aux deux
pays l'issue de l'élection
présidentielle américaine en 2024 et le
probable désengagement qui s'en suivra
ajoute à l'incertitude quant à l'Europe
si elle continue d'assurer son soutien
indéfictible à la cause ukrainienne son
engagement reste limitée la promesse de
fournir 1 million de munitions d'ici au
printemps 2024 n'a pour l'instant été
tenue qu'à 30 % et le passage à une
économie de guerre voulue par certains
responsables européens est resté l'êre
morte